rejoignez-moi sur patréon pour accéder à
l'ensemble de mon contenu inédit des
épisodes spéciaux des cours en visio des
apérophilos un moyen simple de soutenir
mon travail tout en vous donnant matière
à penser je vous attends sur pas très
one le lien est dans la description
bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on va parler de Paul
Lafargue
paulafargue est un journaliste et homme
politique français né en 1842 c'était le
genre de Karl Marx il était marié à sa
deuxième fille Laura
comme Marx Lafargue était un militant
socialiste il a passé de nombreuses
années à diffuser l'oeuvre de Marx et on
le connaît surtout pour un petit essai
qu'il a publié en 1880 et qui s'intitule
le droit à la paresse c'est un essai qui
a beaucoup marqué les esprits en raison
d'abord de son style très satirique très
irrévérencieux mais il a aussi marqué
les esprits pour des raisons de fond car
c'était la première fois qu'un militant
socialiste critiqué de manière aussi
radicale ce qu'on appelle la valeur
travail
la plupart des socialistes ne critiquent
pas le travail ils critique
l'exploitation des travailleurs c'est
pas la même chose ils critiquent le fait
que le travail soit au service de la
classe capitaliste
autrement dit ce que critique la plupart
des socialistes c'est l'organisation du
travail le fait qu'il soit une source
d'inégalité alors que pour la Fargue le
problème est plus profond il ne s'agit
pas seulement de critiquer
l'organisation capitaliste du travail il
s'agit de critiquer l'idéologie du
travail le fait que le travail soit
considéré comme une valeur
au point que les travailleurs eux-mêmes
prônent la valeur travail
ce que nous dit la Fargue c'est que le
travail n'est pas une valeur
qu'il n'est pas une vertu
mais qu'il est d'abord une souffrance
je vous renvoie ici à l'étymologie du
mot travail tripalium qui en latin
désigne un instrument de torture donc le
projet de la Fargue ça va être de
montrer en quoi le travail constitue une
malédiction c'est le mot qui l'emploie
c'est-à-dire en quoi il n'est pas
vecteur d'épanouissement mais au
contraire vecteur de souffrance et même
de dégénérescence
alors avant d'entrer dans l'analyse du
livre de la Fargue dont je rappelle que
c'est un livre satirique avec une grande
part de provocation donc on ne va pas
l'analyser comme un traité philosophique
on va plutôt essayer d'en dégager les
axes de réflexion mais avant ça
j'aimerais compléter ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure sur la conception
qu'avait les socialistes du travail
le socialisme c'est une notion qui
englobe un large éventail de doctrines
mais il y a néanmoins quelques principes
de base le premier principe c'est la
propriété collective en tout cas la
propriété collective des moyens de
production concrètement ça veut dire
qu'être socialiste c'est être pour que
les entreprises n'appartiennent pas à un
propriétaire privé à un individu
particulier mais qu'elle appartiennent
aux travailleurs qui la font fonctionner
selon l'idée que sans les travailleurs
l'entreprise ne peut pas fonctionner et
qu'il n'y a aucune raison que ce soit le
propriétaire de l'entreprise qui
s'enrichissent sur le dos des
travailleurs
la propriété collective des moyens de
production c'est donc ce qui met un
terme à l'exploitation puisque le but
n'est plus de faire un maximum de
profits mais de fournir des biens et des
services utiles à la société
il existe une version moins radicale de
cette idée c'est la propriété publique
la propriété publique c'est quand
l'entreprise n'appartient pas
directement au travailleur mais à l'état
et d'ailleurs il y a beaucoup de
socialistes qui critiquent la propriété
publique justement parce que l'État
c'est pas les travailleurs on trouve
cette critique par exemple chez les
anarchos syndicalistes les anarchos
syndicalistes sont pour l'autogestion
parce qu'il se méfie de l'état de la
tendance intrusive de l'État en clair
parce qu'ils estiment que l'État est une
instance de contrôle
donc premier principe du socialisme la
propriété collective
deuxième principe du socialisme qui va
de pair avec le premier l'égalité plus
précisément l'égalité sociale parce que
l'égalité en soi ça ne veut rien dire
les êtres humains ne sont pas égaux il y
en a des plus forts et des plus faibles
des plus adaptés et des moins adaptés
l'égalité sociale c'est ce qui consiste
à tendre vers une égalité des droits et
des moyens de subsistance
à réduire les écarts de richesse entre
les plus riches et les plus pauvres
a donné plus à ceux qui ont moins et
moins à ceux qui ont plus le principe
d'égalité implique donc l'idée d'une
compensation raison pour laquelle au
lieu de parler d'égalité il sera en fait
plus juste de parler d'équité l'équité
c'est l'harmonisation des inégalités
c'est la formule popularisée par Marx
dans le programme de Gotha de chacun
selon ses capacités à chacun selon ses
besoins
il y a un des cinq vous trouverez
facilement sur Internet qui illustrent
la différence entre l'égalité et
l'équité on y voit trois personnes une
grande une moyenne et une petite qui
passe la tête par dessus une clôture
pour regarder un match de baseball et
pour les aider à mieux y voir on leur a
donné une caisse en bois pour qu'il
puisse se surélever
sauf que le plus grand des trois n'a pas
besoin de cette caisse il est
suffisamment grand pour pouvoir voir
par-dessus la clôture
le moyen ne serait pas assez grand pour
voir par dessus la clôture s'il n'avait
pas la caisse mais avec la caisse il y
voit
alors que le plus petit est encore trop
bas même avec la caisse
ça ça représente l'égalité on donne à
chacun la même chose
mais sauf qu'en faisant ça en donnant à
chacun la même chose à l'arrivée on n'a
pas compensé les inégalités au contraire
on les a creusés
sur le deuxième dessin le plus grand a
donné sa caisse au plus petit qui
maintenant on a deux et qui donc peut
voir par-dessus la clôture le moyen lui
a toujours sa caisse résultat tout le
monde peut voir le match
ils sont égaux en résultat tout en étant
inégaux en distribution des ressources
c'est ça l'équité l'égalité par la
compensation
donc propriété collective égalité et
enfin troisième principe
l'épanouissement humain le socialisme
vise l'épanouissement humain
alors vous allez me dire oui mais tout
le monde vise l'épanouissement humain
c'est pas propre au socialisme il n'y a
aucun mouvement il n'y a aucune
idéologie politique qui prône le malheur
et la souffrance
même le libéralisme prône
l'épanouissement humain oui c'est vrai
mais la différence c'est que dans une
vision libérale dans une vision
capitaliste si on veut être tout à fait
précis
l'épanouissement passe par
l'enrichissement et le travail c'est le
moyen d'accéder à l'enrichissement
alors que pour les socialistes
l'épanouissement ne passe pas par
l'enrichissement
il passe par le loisir par le plaisir
par le temps libre pour les capitalistes
le temps c'est de l'argent pour les
socialistes l'argent c'est ce qui nous
vole notre temps
parce qu'une vie dédiée à s'enrichir
c'est une vie dédiée à travailler
donc c'est une vie dont on profite plus
et ça c'est important de le préciser
parce que ça va nous permettre de mieux
comprendre les raisons pour lesquelles
la Fargue critique la valeur travail
le droit à la paresse c'est d'abord le
droit à l'épanouissement humain le droit
de se retirer de la machine
productiviste pour ne plus être son
esclave
parce que c'est ça la conséquence de la
vision capitaliste du travail
l'idée que la richesse ne serait plus un
moyen mais une fin en soi
s'enrichir pour s'enrichir et que donc
le travail c'est-à-dire le moyen d'un
moyen le moyen de s'enrichir pour
s'épanouir serait le seul et unique but
de notre vie
mais sauf que la vie ne se résume pas au
travail la vie c'est aussi avoir du
temps libre
et employer ce temps libre à des
activités qui nous rendent heureux
la lecture le jeu l'amour
toutes ces choses qu'on a hâte de
pouvoir faire quand on a fini de
travailler
et c'est là où la Fargue va plus loin
que la plupart des socialistes à savoir
qu'il ne prône pas seulement le loisir
mais la paresse
quelle est la différence la différence
c'est que le loisir repose sur
l'activité
tandis que la paresse repose sur
l'inactivité le loisir c'est aller se
balader en forêt c'est jouer au bowling
ou faire un tour de moto
la paresse c'est ne rien faire
étymologiquement loisir ça vient de
liquérer qui veut dire ce qui est permis
le loisir c'est une permission une
permission de faire ce qu'on a envie de
faire
tandis que paresse pigritia c'est la
répugnance à l'effort
donc loisir ne veut pas dire paresse et
par reste veut pas dire repos puisque le
repos c'est justement ce qui fait suite
au travail
le repos c'est l'inactivité qui permet
de renouveler notre énergie de la
restaurer avant de se remettre au
travail
c'est pour ça que dans une logique
capitaliste le repos n'est pas opposé au
travail
le repos est intégré au travail
le travailleur c'est une énergie
renouvelable
pour en terminer sur la distinction
loisirs paresse repos bien sûr que la
Fargue exagère quand il réclame un droit
à la paresse c'est volontaire ce qu'il
veut dire c'est que nous avons tellement
incorporé la logique du travail la
logique de l'épuisement par le travail
que nous avons oublié que la finalité de
l'existence c'est le bonheur
pas l'effort pas la productivité
nous avons oublié que la finalité
c'était nous et que si le travail est
effectivement nécessaire il ne l'est que
pour satisfaire nos besoins fondamentaux
et tout l'objet de sa critique c'est de
dire que les travailleurs se sont
laissés corrompre par l'idéologie du
travail
et c'est ce qu'on va voir maintenant
pour la Fargue ce qu'on appelle la
valeur travail
est en réalité une invention des
capitalistes pour pouvoir mieux
exploiter les travailleurs
pour leur faire croire que le travail
est nécessaire à leur épanouissement
alors que les premiers bénéficiaires du
travail ce ne sont pas les travailleurs
ce sont ceux qui les exploitent
facile de prôner la valeur travail quand
on s'enrichit sur le travail des autres
on n'est pas concerné par le travail
c'est ça le piège capitaliste
avoir fait passer pour une valeur ce qui
correspond en réalité à un besoin du
capitalisme
le besoin de produire toujours plus pour
accumuler toujours plus
il faut ici rappeler la signification du
mot prolétaire le prolétaire c'est celui
qui ne possède rien d'autre que sa force
de travail le prolétaire c'est donc la
batterie de la machine capitaliste une
batterie qu'on recharge c'est le repos
une batterie qu'on remplace quant elle
est hors service quand elle est
littéralement morte vous voyez tout ce
champ lexical
hors service qui ne sert plus
inopérante opéra c'est l'œuvre en latin
œuvre au sens de travail comme quand on
parle d'un maître d'oeuvre et qui a
donné ouvrier
quand une batterie marche elle
fonctionne
elle remplit sa fonction quand on
l'utilise elle s'épuise
et une bonne batterie c'est une batterie
qui tient longtemps
tout ça pour dire que ce que dénonce la
Fargue c'est la tentative de faire
passer le travail pour une valeur
positive alors qu'il s'agit
objectivement d'un levier de la
domination
et c'est là qu'on retrouve le discours
de Marx sur l'aliénation idéologique du
prolétariat autrement dit sur le fait
que l'idéologie de la classe dominante
en l'occurrence de la classe capitaliste
c'est l'idéologie qui profite au
capitalisme
l'idéologie du travail c'est donc
l'idéologie qui permet de faire
travailler les prolétaires sans avoir
besoin de les contraindre puisque
l'idéologie permet le consentement
quand vous persuadez quelqu'un que telle
chose est bonne quand il finit par être
intimement convaincu que cette chose est
bonne il va la faire de lui-même
vous n'aurez plus besoin de lui imposer
c'est ça la force de l'idéologie
la force de la représentation
pour la Fargue la valeur travail c'est
la clé de voûte de l'idéologie
capitaliste
puisqu'une fois que le travailleur croit
à la valeur travail il concentre au
travail
autrement dit il consend à sa propre
exploitation
la première phrase du droit à la paresse
résume tout le propos de la Fargue je
cite une étrange folie possède les
classes ouvrières des nations ou règne
la civilisation capitaliste cette folie
trame à sa suite des misères
individuelles et sociales qui depuis
deux siècles torture la triste humanité
cette folie c'est l'amour du travail fin
de citation
pourquoi c'est une folie
parce que le travail nous dit la phare
et la cause d'une dégénérescence
physique et intellectuelle en un mot le
travail nous détruit
et pourtant nous dit la Fargue les
travailleurs aiment le travail
autrement dit ils aiment quelque chose
qu'il est détruit
il y aurait donc selon la Fargue un
masochisme prolétariat
un jouir dans la douleur pour reprendre
l'expression de Dany Robert Dufour
la question qui se pose c'est de savoir
d'où vient ce masochisme
autrement dit comment l'amour du travail
a-t-il réussi à coloniser autant les
esprits y compris de ceux qui ont
souffrent
la réponse de la Fargue c'est que la
valeur travail est défendue par les
trois corporations qui façonnent
l'opinion
ces trois corporations sont les
économistes les moralistes et les
prêtres
les économistes bon bah ça on l'a vu
tout à l'heure la glorification du
travail et leur métier en particulier du
travail des autres puisque plus les
ouvriers travaillent plus les
propriétaires s'enrichissent
donc quand les économistes disent que le
travail mène à la prospérité ce qui ne
disent pas c'est qu'il mène à la
prospérité des bourgeois
on peut penser ici à Adam Smith
économiste libéral du XVIIIe siècle qui
célèbre la prospérité des nations par le
travail et par le marché libre mais qui
ne remet jamais en cause le principe de
l'exploitation
donc premier défenseur de la valeur
travail les économistes
deuxième défenseur de la valeur travail
les moralistes
la phare remarque que les moralistes
font eux aussi les loges du travail non
pas tant parce qu'il engendrerait la
prospérité mais parce qu'il permettrait
de corriger les vices
le travail frais de nous des gens plus
droits plus honnêtes plus raisonnable
il nous détournerait des passions
comme le disait Nietzsche le travail et
la meilleure des polices
parce qu'il nous épuisent de nos forces
et parce qu'ils nous détourne de la
révolte
la morale du travail on la trouve déjà
chez Voltaire lorsqu'il écrit le travail
éloigne l'homme de trois grands mots
l'ennui le vice et le besoin
on peut pas être plus clair
donc ça c'était pour la deuxième
Corporation qui défend la valeur travail
les moralistes
troisième défenseur de la valeur travail
les prêtres
alors les prêtres c'est intéressant
parce que dans son livre la farce
s'amuse à dire qu'en promouvant la
valeur travail les prêtres vont à
l'encontre de ce que dit leur religion
il dit que si on suivait vraiment les
prescriptions bibliques on devrait pas
prôner le travail mais qu'on devrait
prôner la paresse
par exemple il dit que Dieu prône le
droit à la paresse parce qu'il a créé le
monde en six jours et qu'ensuite il
s'est reposé pour l'éternité bon on sait
que c'est pas exactement ça qui est
écrit dans la Bible dans la Bible il est
écrit que Dieu s'est reposé le septième
jour et qu'il a sanctifié le septième
jour comme étant le jour du repos
donc on est plutôt dans de la
provocation ici de la part de la Fargue
puisque précisément dans le
christianisme la paresse est condamnée
la paresse c'est l'un des sept péchés
capitaux dans la Genèse Dieu ne dit pas
à l'homme passez vos journées à dormir
il dit soumettez la terre
croissez et multiplier
et quand Adam et Eve sont expulsés du
jardin d'Éden leur punition c'est
l'obligation du travail
il tient donc tu gagneras ton pain à la
sueur de ton front dans la Bible il est
écrit celui qui amasse pendant l'été est
un fils prudent celui qui dort pendant
la moisson est un fils qui fait honte il
est écrit va vers la fourmi paresseux
considère ses voies et devient sage elle
prépare en été sa nourriture elle amasse
pendant la moisson de quoi manger
jusqu'à quand paresseux resteras-tu
couché
donc on n'est pas vraiment dans les
loges de la paresse
et d'ailleurs si on va aller encore plus
loin le christianisme est fondé sur une
distinction entre l'ici-bas et l'au-delà
et l'ici-bas autrement dit la vie
terrestre c'est une vie faite de
souffrance
c'est une vie faite de douleur des
preuves
et de corruption
nous sommes les enfants du péché
originel donc de la culpabilité et la
souffrance c'est le prix à payer pour
racheter notre culpabilité
et donc dans notre inconscient collectif
même si nous ne sommes plus
officiellement dans un pays chrétien
nous restons en partie programmée par
des générations et des générations
d'incultation de la morale chrétienne
et donc d'incultation de l'idée que nous
sommes tous des pêcheurs
et ça c'est pas quelque chose qui
disparaît du jour au lendemain
quelqu'un qui a grandi avec une forte
culpabilisation familiale il va pas s'en
libérer le jour il va partir de chez ses
parents c'est quelque chose qui marque
en profondeur
et donc il n'est pas du tout absurde
considérer que nous sommes
culturellement conditionnés accepter
notre souffrance
voir à la légitimer inconsciemment
et pour rester dans le thème de la
religion et du rapport entre religion et
travail le protestantisme c'est une
religion qui non seulement prône la
valeur travail mais qui est également
justifie théologiquement le capitalisme
je vous renvoie à ce sujet au livre de
Max Weber l'éthique protestante ou
l'esprit du capitalisme qui permet de
comprendre pourquoi les pays
anglo-saxons payent protestants donc ont
été les premiers à développer le
capitalisme
il y a des raisons culturelles à ça
parce que le protestantisme contient
l'idée que le fait de s'enrichir par le
travail c'est une manière pour Dieu de
récompenser les élus
il y a ma main non pour ça ça s'appelle
l'évangile de la prospérité
et l'Évangile de la prospérité enseigne
que le fait de s'enrichir est un signe
d'élection divine tandis que la pauvreté
serait le signe d'une punition divine
c'est quelque chose de réel
et c'est ce qui fait que dans une
logique protestante gagner beaucoup
d'argent c'est pas un problème
parce que ça permet d'aider son prochain
parce que plus on gagne d'argent plus on
fait marcher l'économie
plus on crée de l'emploi donc on
participe à la maximisation du bien-être
c'est l'argument utilisé par Peter
Singer l'inventeur de l'altruisme
efficace quand il dit le meilleur moyen
de faire le bien sur terre c'est de
gagner beaucoup d'argent
alors nous en France nous sommes de
traditions catholique donc on n'aime pas
trop ce genre de discours on est
davantage porté sur la culpabilisation
sur l'effort des intéressés que sur
l'enrichissement l'argent en France
c'est un peu tabou mais aux États-Unis
pays protestants c'est pas du tout
parce qu'aux États-Unis il y a une
culture de la réussite matérielle qui
trouve son origine dans l'éthique
protestante
donc chaque culture à ces particularités
chaque pays a son propre paradigme mais
ce que nous dit Lafargue c'est que le
paradigme capitaliste a besoin de la
valeur travail et que ce soit par
l'argument de la prospérité par
l'argument de la morale ou par la
culpabilisation chrétienne les
capitalistes ont trouvé le moyen de
faire adhérer les prolétaires au dogme
du travail
et une fois que les prolétaires adhèrent
au dogme du travail il travaille sans
qu'on ait besoin de les contraindre
c'est ça l'aliénation
le droit à la paresse a été publié en
il y a une origine à ce texte
c'était une réponse au livre d'un autre
auteur socialiste Louis Blanc qui
s'intitulait Le droit au travail
le blanc n'avait pas des idées aussi
radicales que la Fargue il était moins
marxiste plus réformiste mais c'était
quand même si vous motorisez cette
appréciation un vrai socialiste
c'est quelqu'un qui a créé les ateliers
sociaux qui devaient permettre
l'auto-organisation des travailleurs
c'est quelqu'un qui était pour la
nationalisation des banques pour le
crédit à taux zéro pour les associations
pour une assurance d'État bref Louis
Blanc c'était pas un jaune
ce n'était pas un socialiste de façade
et pourtant il y a un désaccord
fondamental entre la Fargue et les
socialistes comme Louis Blanc qui est
que pour la Fargue les socialistes
défendent beaucoup trop le travail
pas pour les mêmes raisons que les
capitalistes mais le défendent quand
même
au nom de quoi est-ce qu'il le défende
il le défende au nom de la dignité
ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire tout bêtement que si vous
n'avez pas de travail vous ne gagnez pas
d'argent et si vous ne gagnez pas
d'argent vous ne pouvez pas vivre
décemment
les inactifs les improductifs vivent
dans des conditions matérielles
fortement dégradées parfois contraint à
la mendicité voire à l'illégalité ne pas
avoir de travail au 19e siècle ce
n'était pas la même chose que ne pas
avoir de travail après 1958 quand a été
créé l'assurance chômage
on ne touchait pas d'allocation on ne
touchait pas le revenu minimum
d'insertion donc pour les socialistes
comme Louis Blanc le travail n'était pas
vu comme une malédiction il était vu au
contraire comme un moyen de vivre
dignement
ça permettait de ne pas mourir de faim
ou de froid dans la rue
et c'est là qui est né historiquement la
revendication d'un droit au travail le
droit au travail c'était le droit
d'avoir un emploi pour pouvoir survivre
mais sauf que ça pour la Fargue c'est un
leurre
c'est un leurre parce qu'en réalité la
richesse existe
l'argent existe
et où est l'argent il est dans les mains
des capitalistes
c'est même capitalistes qui exploite les
travailleurs donc techniquement ce qui
ne travaillent pas pourrait recevoir de
l'argent il suffirait de le prendre au
capitaliste
et c'est d'autant plus vrai qu'avec les
progrès de l'industrie avec la
mécanisation les coûts de production
sont beaucoup plus faibles et des coûts
de production plus faibles ça signifie
des bénéfices plus importants
alors d'où vient le problème
et bien le problème il est très simple
c'est l'égoïsme de la classe capitaliste
c'est son besoin d'accumuler toujours
plus
c'est son hubris
le Brice c'est un mot grec qu'on
retrouve beaucoup dans la philosophie
antique et qui désigne la démesure
le Brice c'est l'excès
à un niveau qui en devient pathologique
parce qu’il entraîne une incapacité à la
modération
une incapacité à la limitation
la fraction des auteurs grecs dont le
droit à la paresse il rappelle cette
idée très épicurienne qui est que c'est
la mesure de notre consommation était le
besoin simplement le besoin il n'y
aurait pas d'exploitation
parce qu'il n'y aurait pas de désir
d'accumuler plus que ce qu'il nous faut
pour survivre
le besoin ne connaît pas l'excès par
définition
donc si on se contentait de consommer ce
dont on avait besoin réellement besoin
le capitalisme n'aurait pas lieu d'être
la productivité n'aurait pas lieu d'être
donc quand la phare critique le travail
ce qu'il critique en arrière-plan c'est
lubrissent
c'est la pathologie de l'accumulation
qui entraîne la pathologie de
l'exploitation dans une société non
capitaliste dans une société qui n'est
pas atteinte par lubrise productiviste
on exploite pas l'être humain
on en fait pas un outil au service de
l'accumulation
et d'ailleurs on exploite pas non plus
la nature
on lui prélève seulement de quoi
satisfaire nos besoins
c'est ce que faisait les
chasseurs-cueilleurs les
chasseurs-cueilleurs qui à proprement
parler ne travaillaient pas
il travaillait bien sûr au sens où la
chasse c'est un travail au sens où
construire un abri et l'entretenir c'est
un travail
mais ne travaillez pas au sens où le
travail n'existait pas en dehors de la
satisfaction des besoins
avec la révolution agricole on est passé
de l'air du prélèvement à l'air de
l'exploitation
on produisait au-delà du besoin
ça avait un intérêt
l'anticipation
l'anticipation de l'hiver
l'anticipation de la sécheresse
l'anticipation du manque
la révolution agricole c'est le moment
où l'homme cigale devient homme fourmi
il cultive il fait des provisions il
stock
mais il souffre
c'est l'angoisse du lendemain qui a
engendré la folie productiviste
et c'est cette folie dont les
travailleurs payent encore le prix de
nos jours
alors il y a quand même chez Lafargue
une manière de parler des travailleurs
qui peut nous sembler gênante
gênante au sens où il exprime un certain
mépris pour les travailleurs
et ça c'est un paradoxe intéressant
c'est un paradoxe intéressant parce que
dans les courants socialistes on a
l'habitude de caresser les travailleurs
dans le sens du poil on a l'habitude de
considérer les travailleurs comme des
victimes comme les victimes du
capitalisme
capitaliste sont les dominants en tant
que dominant ce sont eux qui ont le
pouvoir les prolétaires n'ont pas le
pouvoir et donc s'ils sont exploités
c'est parce qu'ils n'ont pas le choix ce
sont les victimes et on ne culpabilise
pas les victimes
Lafargue a un point de vue beaucoup
moins complaisant pour lui les
travailleurs sont en partie responsables
de leur exploitation
ils en sont même les complices
on rejoint ici la position de la Boétie
la servitude volontaire la fac de cite
pas la Boétie mais certaines de ces
phrases semblent avoir été écrite par La
Boétie exemple je cite les prolétaires
ont livré au baron de l'industrie leur
femme et leurs enfants de leur propre
main ils ont démoli leur foyer
domestiques de leur propre main ils ont
taré le lait de leurs femmes les
malheureuses enceintes et allaitant leur
bébé ont dû aller dans les mines et les
manufactures tendre les Chine et épuiser
leur nerfs de leur propre main ils ont
brisé la vie et la vigueur de leurs
enfants ont au prolétaire fin de
citation
donc vous voyez que ce qui caractérise
le discours de la Fargue c'est l'anti
démagogie la démagogie c'est le fait de
défendre le peuple pour le flatter pour
éventuellement récolter ces suffrages
la démagogie c'est dire par exemple que
récurer les toilettes publiques n'est
pas une activité dégradante que ça peut
même être une activité épanouissante
ce que tout le monde sait être faux
a commencé par ceux qui le font mais
qu'on s'oblige à penser parce qu'on
croit qu'en disant ça on défend les
travailleurs
l'anti démagogie c'est de dire que
récurer les toilettes publiques ce n'est
pas épanouissant
c'est avilissant
c'est de dire que tout travail et a
fortiori tout travail bénéficie non pas
aux travailleurs mais à celui qui
l'exploite est un asservissement
une négation de notre humanité
et donc ça donne des phrases du genre
ont au prolétariat français des esclaves
seuls étaient capables d'une telle
bassesse il faudrait 20 ans de
civilisation capitaliste à un Grec des
temps héroïques pour concevoir un tel
avissement
donc quand on lit ça on pourrait se dire
que la Fargue n'est finalement pas
vraiment du côté des travailleurs
mais qui n'est qu'un petit aristocrate
anarchiste une sorte de contemplateur de
la misère de poètes de la misère qui ne
dénonce le pouvoir que pour l'esthétique
c'est pas aussi simple
si on veut comprendre le mépris que la
Fargue affiche envers les prolétaires
envers ceux qui se soumettent à
l'exploitation capitaliste il faut
garder à l'esprit que la Fargue souhaite
une révolution proléléarienne
et en bon marxiste il pense que la
révolution prolétariale aura lieu quand
les travailleurs auront accédé à la
conscience de classe
la conscience de classe c'est le fait
d'être conscient d'appartenir à une
certaine classe sociale de ne pas se
voir simplement comme un individu ou
comme un citoyen du monde parce que ça
ce sont des mots creux ce sont des mots
abstraits le prolétaire n'est pas juste
un individu il est le membre d'un sujet
collectif qui s'appelle le prolétariat
et ce prolétariat a un rôle historique
celui de renverser la classe capitaliste
et le jour où tous les prolétaires
seront conscients d'être les membres
d'un sujet collectif le jour ils seront
conscients d'avoir une mission
historique
ils instaureront un rapport de force
et contenu du nombre contenu du fait que
les prolétaires constituent l'écrasante
majorité de la population
ils sont certains de l'emporter face au
capitaliste
si tous les prolétaires cessent de
travailler le capitalisme s'effondre si
tous les prolétaires descendent dans la
rue la police ne pourra pas les contenir
donc la force du prolétariat c'est la
force du nombre
mais le nombre ne sert à rien si les
travailleurs ne s'unissent pas
et pour qu'ils s'unissent il faut qu'ils
aient conscience de leur unité
il faut qu'ils aient une conscience de
classe
j'en reviens à la Fargue que fait la
Fargue quand il manque de respect au
travailleur quand il est traite de
soumis quand il est traite de fou
il est provoque
provoqué ça veut dire faire venir
faire naître
la Fargue manque de respect aux
travailleurs pour provoquer en eux une
réaction
pour exciter leur fierté pour exciter
leur désir de révolte
quand il se moque de leur revendication
d'un droit au travail c'est pour dire
qu'au lieu de réclamer du travail il
ferait mieux d'aller piller les magasins
il ferait mieux d'aller détruire les
usines
autrement dit il veut les rendre honteux
de leur soumission à l'ordre capitaliste
il veut les pousser à bout
et quel meilleur moyen d'inciter à la
révolte que de pousser à bout
il y a les socialistes qui font l'éloge
du travail ailleurs
qui célèbre son mérite qui célèbre sa
force son courage
et il y a les socialistes comme la
Fargue qui pensent qu'on ne rend pas
service au peuple en célébrant la
soumission
en célébrant l'acceptation et la
passivité
la FARC pense que pour qu'il y a
révolution il faut qu'il y ait refus
car le refus c'est le premier pas vers
la révolte
et la révolte c'est le premier pas vers
la révolution
pour la Fargue le prolétariat est un
lion qui s'ignore
c'est un lion qui s'est laissé maîtriser
qui s'est laissé domestiquer
qui se laisse traiter comme du bétail
pour qu'il devienne ce qu'il est pour
que son pour soi rejoigne son nom soit
il faut que le prolétariat prenne
conscience de ce qu'il est
qu'ils prennent conscience qu'il est un
lion
un lion prêt à bondir de sa cage et à
dévorer ce qui a cherché à le dévorer à
savoir le capitalisme
je cite
dans la société capitaliste le travail
et la cause de toute dégénérescence
intellectuelle de toutes déformation
organique comparer le pur sang des
écuries de Rothschild servis par une
valtaille de biman à la lourde brute des
fermes normandes qui labourent la terre
chariotte le fumier engrange la moisson
regardez le noble sauvage que les
missionnaires du commerce et les
commerçants de la religion n'ont pas
encore corrompu avec le christianisme la
syphilis et le dogme du travail et
regardez ensuite nos misérables servants
de machines et cependant le prolétariat
la grande classe qui embrasse tous les
producteurs des nations civilisées la
classe qui en s'émancipant émancipera
l'humanité du travail servile et fera de
l'animal humain un être libre le
prolétariat trahissant ses instincts
méconnaissance à mission historique
s'est laissée pervertir par le dogme du
travail rue des terribles a été son
châtiment toutes les misères
individuelles et sociales sont nées de
sa passion pour le travail mais
assourdit et idiotisé par leur propre
hurlements les économistes de répondre
travailler toujours pour créer votre
bien-être et au nom de la mensuétude
chrétienne un prêtre de l'Église
anglicane le révérendum salle maudit
travailler nuit et jour en travaillant
vous faites croître votre misère et
votre misère nous dispense de vous
imposer le travail par la force de la
loi l'imposition légale du travail donne
trop de peine exigent trop de violence
et fait trop de bruit la fin au
contraire et non seulement une pression
paisible silencieuse incessante mais
comme le mobile le plus naturel du
travail et de l'industrie elle provoque
aussi les efforts les plus puissants
travailler prolétaire pour agrandir la
fortune sociale et vos misères visuel
travailler travailler pour que devenant
plus pauvre vous ayez plus de raison de
travailler et d'être misérable telle est
la loi inexorable de la production
capitaliste au lieu de profiter des
moments de crise pour une distribution
générale des produits et un gaudissement
universel les ouvriers crevant de faim
s'en vont battre de leur tête les portes
de l'atelier avec des figures ave des
corps amaigris des discours piteux ils
assaillent les fabricants bon monsieur
Chagot doux monsieur Schneider
donnez-nous du travail ce n'est pas la
fin mais la passion du travail qui nous
tourmente et ces misérables qui ont à
peine la force de se tenir debout vendre
12 et 14 heures de travail deux fois
moins cher que lorsqu'ils avaient du
pain sur la planche et les philanthropes
de l'industrie de profiter des chômages
pour fabriquer un meilleur marché ces
misères individuelles et sociales
s’évanouiront comme les hyènes et les
chacals à l'approche du
quand le prolétariat dira je le veux
mais pour qu'il parvienne à la
conscience de sa force il faut que le
prolétariat full au pied les préjugés de
la morale chrétienne économique libre
penseuse il faut qu'il retourne à ses
instincts naturels
et plus sacré que les physiques droits
de l'homme concocté par les avocats
métaphysiciens de la révolution
bourgeoise qu'il se contraignent à ne
travailler que trois heures par jour à
feignanter et bombancer le reste de la
journée et de la nuit si des racines de
son cœur le vice qu'il a domine et
avilie sa nature la classe ouvrière se
levait dans sa force terrible non pour
réclamer les droits de l'homme qui ne
sont que les droits de l'exploitation
capitaliste non pour réclamer le droit
au travail qui n'est que le droit à la
misère mais pour forger une loi des
reins défendant à tout homme de
travailler plus de trois heures par jour
la terre la vieille terre frémissante
allégresse sans tirer bondir en elle un
nouvel univers
défendre les travailleurs ça n'implique
effectivement pas de défendre le travail
mais la question est de savoir pourquoi
travaille-t-on
est-ce qu'on travaille parce qu'on n'a
pas le choix
est-ce qu'on travaille pour engraisser
ce qui nous exploite
ou est-ce qu'on travaille parce que le
travail fait partie de l'essence de
l'homme
c'est ce que pensait Marx
pour Marx le travail et le propre de
l'homme
parce que contrairement à l'animal quand
l'être humain travaille il crée quelque
chose consciemment
ce qu'il crée existe dans son esprit
avant d'exister dans le monde matériel
par le travail l'homme façonne la nature
à son image
il sculpte dans la nature son propre
visage
le travail c'est la matérialisation de
notre conscience
et par cette matérialisation nous
modifions la nature qui nous modifie en
retour
quand l'homme transforme le monde il se
transforme lui-même
et c'est ce va-et-vient permanent entre
le monde et la conscience qui fait de
nous ce que nous sommes
reste à savoir à quoi conduit cette
transformation
est-ce qu'elle conduit à
l'asservissement de la nature
à son épuisement
ou est-ce qu'elle conduit au contraire
à prendre conscience que sans la nature
nous ne sommes rien
je vous remercie
[Musique]